اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ثلاثه من
جنوده واصابه ضابط بنيران شرطي مصري قتل
كذلك على الحدود مع مصر كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي
الملابسات التي احاطت بمقتل الجنود
الاسرائيليين الثلاثه على الحدود مع مصر
وما مغزى التباين في تفسير الواقعه بين
حديث الجيش الاسرائيلي وحديث الجيش المصري
عن مطارده مرتبطه بالمخدرات منعكاسات هذه
العمليه على الداخل الاسرائيلي
وما حدث في الليل هو ان كما هو الحال
دائما يهربوا المخدرات من صحراء السيناء
حاولوا العبور الى صحراء النقب الكتيبه
الاسرائيليه التابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي
المنتشره هناك استطاعت التصدي
للمهربين لكن في الوقت نفسه وفي نقطه
مراقبه اخرى
جديان احدهما ذكر والاخرى انثى تعرضا
لهجوم من شخص ما قتلهما لكننا لا نعرف ما
هي الدوافع وبعد ساعات وبعد الكشف عن ذلك
من جانب الوحده المعنيه بدات الوحده
بالبحث عن الفاعل وعندما عثروا على الفاعل
داخل اسرائيل فتح النار على الجنود وقتل
ثالثا وادى الحادث الى مقتله هو ايضا
الامر ما زال قيد التحقيق من قبل الجانبين
الروايه الاسرائيليه ان هم بيقولوا ان هم
بعد بدء ساعات عشروا على من اطلق النار
كيف عرفت ان هو اللي اطلق النار هل عملت
مظاهرات بين الرصاص اللي كان هو سلاح اللي
كان بيحمله والعيار بتاعه
والرصاص اللي قتل الجنود بتاعكم يعني انا
شايف حضرتك انه السرد الاسرائيلي محتاج
لتدقيق وتمحيصه ان احنا لا ينبغي ان
ناخذوا على عله
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لتبيان الروايات الروايات الروايه
الاسرائيليه نفسها في حضرتك حاجات غير
مقنعه ومحتاجه لتبخير ولذلك الجانب المصري
بيقوم بدراسه الوضع طبعا في اختلاف بين
الروايه
الرسميه الاسرائيليه وما صرح به المتحدث
العسكريين المصري يعني بصفه عامه نشاعر
انه الجانب الاسرائيلي بيكبر وبيضخم من
الحادث اتصال تليفونى بين وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي وزير الدفاع المصري اكيد كبيره
بعض الشيء الجانب الاسرائيلي صعد الموضوع
بشكل لا يتناسب مع الوقائع اللي احنا
استمعنا اليها او قرانا عنها منذ اطلاق
النار اسرائيل مصابه بحاله انفجار شديد
لسببين السبب الاول انه في فشل امني
اسرائيلي صارخ وواضح كالشمس عندما يقتل
منهم ثلاثه جدود اثنان ومن ثم ثالث يعرفوا
ما الذي يجري فهذا يدل على فشل امن كبير
النقطه الثانيه هم حساسون جدا للخسائر
البشريه لا يحتمل حدوث خسائر هذا مجتمع
اصبح مرفه لا يطيق حدوث خسائر وبالتالي
يتفاعل بشكل انفعالي كامل بس الشيء الاهم
هذا الشاب المصري الباسل يعني اما انه
دافع عن نفسه ثم استشهد او انه قام بعمل
وطني مقاوم وفي الحالتين هو في الواقع
شهيد ليس فقط للشعب المصري وانما للشعب
الشعب الفلسطيني والشعب العربيه والذي جرى
يؤكد فشل نظريه نتنياهو وفشل النظريه
الاسرائيليه بشكل عام التي كانت تراهن على
ان وجود اتفاقيات سلام مع بعض الدول او
حتى اتفاقيات تطبيع مع بعض الحكومات ان
ذلك سيعني تطبيع مع الشعوب هذا لم يحدث
ولم يحدث ابدا الشعب المصري والشعب
الاردني لم يطبع مع اسرائيل
ويتعاطف بشكل كامل مع ما يجري في فلسطين
المشاعر لا تستطيع اسرائيل ان توقفها قضيه
الفلسطينيه وما يعانيه الشعب الفلسطيني في
وجدان كل الشعوب العربيه ما فيها الشعبين
الشقيقين في مصر والاردن وبالتالي كل شيء
ممكن ان يحدث اتفاق السلام دوت التزامات
تعاديه بين دولتين وهو غير ملزم بها
وبالتالي حضرتك منذ عام 79 لغايه النهارده
ما فيش مظاهر خالص
لتطبيع على مستوى
الشعب وعلى مستوى المهن والاتحادات
المهنيه ليس ان ذلك حضرتك باوامر او
بتعليمات لا دي حضرتك نبعه من داخل من
بلدان الشعب المصري بس من ناحيه اخرى يعني
انا افضل ننتظر نتائج التحقيق التي الذي
تجريه وتجريه الان القوات المسلحه المصريه
والاجهزه الامنيه المصريه
[تصفيق]
الامور ستهدا لان هناك مصالح حيويه في
التعاون الامني بين هذه البلدان الثلاثه
مصر والاردن واسرائيل وللاسف على اسرائيل
ان تدفن ثلاثه من شبانها لكن لن يكون
الامر اي التداعيات سيكون لها تاثيرات
كبيره بالتاكيد اولا لانها تظهر فشل هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه فشل نتنياهو حكومته
الفاشيه فشل الامني اولا ثانيا كل المؤسسه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه كانت منشغله في
الايام الاخيره بالحديث عن مخاطر هجمات في
الشمال ومخاطر ايران ومخاطر حزب الله
ومخاطر ما تقوم به المقاومه الفلسطينيه
الباسله في الضفه الغربيه في جنين وطولكرم
ونابلس ولم يتوقعوا على الاطلاق هذه
المفاجاه التي جاءتهم من الجنه